this is a great victory for democracy
and for the millions of people who spoke
out against corporate attempt to carve
up the internet more than 1 million
defenders of a free internet signed a
petition did this play a part in the
victory in the battle for net neutrality
whether it did or not
Parliament rubber-stamped the telecoms
package after intense debates
next up the council if passed gone will
be the days of roaming charges and a two
speed internet development aid trade
agreements humanitarian aid or even
military interventions these are just
some of the instruments the EU has up
its sleeve for a strong foreign policy
High Representative Cathy Ashton and the
multi-billion euro budget give the EU a
great springboard to make an impact but
coordinating these means of action is
not so straight away to take on an
attack but not a difficulty see the ble
coordinate as cachaça a treasure a
provocative Shaka a treasure hunt EVGA
socket resolute synonymous a CA tomato
song for our insula posh insult
political career show hotel Intel please
the survival suit obviously complicated
declare a solid also
with dangerous breast implants and
faulty hip replacements there has been
no shortage of medical device scandals
in recent years to better protect
patients MEP s are pushing for stricter
certification procedures and better
implant traceability the challenge now
will be to win over those member states
who stand in opposition to the time they
are under high pressure obviously from
the lobbyists at home I'm different kind
of lobbyism is obviously too strong we
have to wait now and that can take again
months or years till we get whatever we
could then get for patients with the
parliaments greenlight the ball is now
in the council's court